it is with regret and surprise that I  received the news that President Trump  has cancelled his state visit to Denmark  on the 2nd and 3rd September I'd been  looking forward to the visit our  preparations were well underway it was  an opportunity I think to celebrate the  Denmark's close relationship to to us a  discussion has however been raised  raised about a potential sale of  Greenland this has clearly been rejected  by Kim keelson a position that I share  of course this does not change the  character of our good relations and we  will of course from Denmark continue our  ongoing dialogue with the US on how we  can develop our cooperation and deal  with the many common challenges we are  facing